on other day just the other day a man
applied for a job and they told him he
can't get the job because of AF so you
can't tell us to not focus on it when it
is the F he could it didn't happen watch
the news it literally happened the other
day yeah but that's his experience but
if he was smart he's not going to let
that hold him back
that's on the news and he's you can't
tell us you can't tell us to not focus
on it if I walk into a certain place of
my AF the first thing people are going
to do is stare at me and certain places
won't want to give me the job just
because I have want me to tell you
something that's your mindset your mind
you can't tell me to my mind if they
have told me I am not giv you
the
myod that's is my point